shirred the venom movies tagline is the
world has enough superheroes because
this powerful alien symbiote appears to
be an evil man eating menace but have
you ever stopped to consider that venom
may actually be the victim in all of
this give me 15 minutes or honestly
whatever length this video winds up
being because who knows the actual
length of this video isn't finalized
until like five steps after I record
this whatever it lines up being stick
around because I think I'm gonna be able
to change your mind
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that's cringy er than a Peter
Parker dance break
okay maybe not that cringey but closed
today we're talking about venom one of
spider-man's most popular villains
because let's face it who doesn't love
themselves a dark doppelganger storyline
am i right for those of you who need the
quick rundown venom is one of several
alien symbiotes to go around possessing
human hosts in the spider verse giving
them special abilities like
shape-shifting increased strength and um
had normally long tongue in the new
movie journalist Eddie Brock is
investigating the Life Foundation an
organization whose experiments with the
sippy Oates are a whole lot more
sinister than their super generic name
implies when the investigation goes awry
Eddie's body merges with the symbiote
unleashing venom and his ultimate
ability awkward one-liners bullied on
street in all seriousness though there's
an interesting side to venom that no one
has ever really stopped to consider that
he's the victim in all of this and I
don't mean that in the big bad evil
science corporation did experiments on
him or anything like that I mean that
for all the death and destruction that
venom may bring if the symbiote is
really just a lost confused and scared
and team that Eddie Brock might be the
thing that's actually infecting it but
to truly understand why we first have to
understand
parasites you see once you strip away
all the alien goo nonsense venom is the
dictionary definition of a parasite
harassing an organism that lives in or
on another organism gets host and
derives nutrients at the hosts expense
take for instance the case of the
parasitic wasp and the orb-weaving
spiders both of which live in Japan the
female wasp drops her eggs onto the back
of the spider which hatch and then
become a larva in larval form the baby
wasp takes control over the spider
causing it to build a web a web that is
nearly three times stronger than any web
the spider would ever build for itself
in its normal life it sounds a lot like
venom and that increased strength he
gives to his host body's good it
amplifies characteristics of its host
the reason they do this is that the
larvae will soon be helpless in a cocoon
it needs a stronger web to protect it a
web that's heavier duty than what a
spider would typically build once that
web is built a Spider host is killed off
it's no longer useful and just like a
parasite always about that web bam thank
you ma'am but for as similar as a spider
parasite might be to venom there's
actually a better fit when it comes to
the real world toxoplasmosis Gandhi I
which I've talked about very briefly
years ago when one of the earliest and
cringy stepa sowed the game theory haha
that worked
basically toxoplasmosis hijacks the
brain of a rat forcing it to hide out in
the open where it can be found and eaten
by cats bad news for the rat but great
news for the parasite because once it's
inside the cat's stomach it can morph
into a cat compatible form and then also
reproduce inside the cat's digestive
system after reproducing it gets pooped
back out by the cat and gets into the
water supply
where it's once again consumed by the
rats it's like a really gross version of
the circle of life everything the poop
touches will be your home now you'd be
totally forgiven if none of that
immediately reminds you of venom but in
both cases were presented with a
parasite whose behavior and abilities
change based on the thing it's infecting
symbiotes effect Peter Parker and Eddie
Brock in cletus kasady very differently
just like toxoplasmosis changes tactics
whether it's inside of a cat's or inside
of rats or even inside of a human
you see toxoplasmosis can also affect
humans now I'm not gonna say it's gonna
cause you to lay down and mr. Fluffy's
food dish in the hopes of him one day
eating you but studies have shown that
this could have other effects on the
human brain specifically it might be
linked to an increased risk of
schizophrenia according to researchers
at the Stanley Medical Research
Institute quote cat ownership and
childhood has now been reported in three
studies to be significantly more common
in families in which their child is
later diagnosed with schizophrenia or
another serious mental illness and quote
furthermore the researchers finding
quote again suggests that cat ownership
in childhood is significantly more
common in families in which the child
later becomes seriously mentally ill end
quote further stating that an
explanatory mechanism may be Toxoplasma
gondii i now before everyone rushes off
to put mr. fluffy up for adoption I'd
like to point out that there were more
than 40 million people in the US who are
currently suspected to be infected with
the toxoplasmosis parasites and only a
teeny tiny fraction of those are
diagnosed with full-blown schizophrenia
even if the link between the two is
scientifically valid and remember it is
far from certainty the chances of
getting a schizophrenia diagnosis are
still incredibly low just try to be
hygienic and make sure that you're
washing your hands after you empty the
litter box you're doing that right right
anyway the link between Toxoplasma and
schizophrenia is really interesting
because in a lot of ways it parallels
Eddie Brock's relationship with the
venom parasites for instance one of the
main symptoms of both schizophrenia and
the symbiote is psychosis a failure to
understand reality and a higher
propensity for hallucinations and this
is something that is immediately
apparent from the trailer of the new
movie in that trailer Eddie looks into a
car window and sees the reflection of
venom staring back at him this should be
physically impossible the shot is
showing us things as Eddie sees them in
this case he's seeing things that aren't
really there and he is also prone to
auditory hallucinations hearing a voice
call his name
venoms voice commending him now wait I
hear you saying that isn't a
hallucination venom is literally talking
to him and sure that's true but it is
all still happening in his head that
conversation with venom is the textbook
definition of auditory hallucinations
and one of the clearest signs that Eddie
might be headed off to schizophrenia but
why does any of this matter I mean sure
Menem and toxoplasmosis might share some
similarities but even I with my
over-the-top theories won't go so far as
to say that the symbiote is just a hyper
evolved form of this cat parasites I
don't need another Deadpool as earnest
Hemmingway moment on my hands no the
reason I bring up the parallels here is
that whether we're talking about
parasitic wasps parasites that warp rat
brains or fictional alien parasites one
thing connects all of them a need for
survival it's easy to forget but
parasites are fighting for survival just
like any other living creature and
they're using whatever techniques that
they have at their disposal it's why the
wasp gets the spider to build a stronger
web so it can reproduce it's why
Toxoplasma forces the rat to get eaten
so it can reproduce inside of the cat's
stomach but now take a moment to look at
Venom's behavior we see him presumably
eat a guy in the middle of a convenience
store and then just leave a witness if
you need to eat a human to survive why
wouldn't you just track down victims to
eat in I don't know dark secluded
alleyways instead of I don't know the
middle of the street where six people
yes
six people count'em are watching one of
whom appears to be recording the whole
thing on a cell phone
behaviors like this result in Eddie and
my proxy venom repeatedly getting
attacked by thugs having to run away
having to fight for their lives in
spider-man 3 venom being evil gets
himself the worst enemy possible
spider-man any way you slice it this
behavior is simply not conducive to
helping venom survive it is instead
doing the exact opposite and putting him
at active risk so what is really going
on here well it's all explained by
toxoplasmosis you see changing rats
behavior so that they get eaten by cats
helps the Toxoplasma survive and
reproduce inducing psychosis in humans
however does none
those things it is a loss for the human
who starts to develop mental issues but
it's also a loss for the Toxoplasma who
can't move on from the human to the
cat's digestive tract and reproduce
because well there just aren't that many
man-eating cats out there
the problem is Toxoplasma didn't evolve
to exist in humans it evolved for the
cat rat style of life the fact that it
also happens to affect humans is
entirely accidental an unintended side
effect this relates to a field cult so
gnosis infectious diseases that begin in
animals but can eventually be
transmitted into humans like bovine
spongiform encephalopathy probably
better known as mad cow disease there's
also bird flu and probably the single
most notorious example in history the
Black Death in 14th century Europe which
was spread by rat fleas that went on to
kill human hosts what are the reasons
that these kinds of diseases can be so
fatal to humans is that they didn't
evolve to affect humans they evolved to
affect some other animal and the fact
that they can infect and kill humans is
just the accidental side effect which is
usually a pretty bad evolutionary
strategy if you're a parasite but this
is what seems to be happening in the
case of the symbiotes we're so used to
seeing venom and other symbiotes like
carnage and scream attaching to human
hosts that you might make the mistake of
assuming that the symbiotes naturally
exist to bond with humans but that's not
the case at all canonically speaking the
symbiotes were originally created by the
primordial deity null in order to
slaughter the Celestials basically space
gods from the beginning of time
you remember know we're from the
guardians of galaxy movies I was in the
shape of a head oh yeah in the comics
that's technically a celestial severed
head where people are parking their
boats anyway it shouldn't come as a big
surprise that an organism created in a
separate part of the galaxy with the
intent of bonding with space jeez I
would probably experience unintended
side effects when trying to bond with a
human host it's a learning process which
might explain why Venom's behavior
sometimes seems erratic at best and
completely against his own survival at
worst in fact if anything it might be
the symbiotes themselves who are
affected more by this bonding process we
often see the Venom symbiote is
something who takes control of humans
the link works both ways though the
symbiotes were originally created with
evil intentions one of the quirks of
their programming is that they take on
some attributes of their hosts in many
cases symbiotes feel that their
existence has no meaning and one of the
reasons they bond with a host is to give
their lives a simple purpose this is one
of the reasons why when venom first
bonded with Peter Parker in the comics
the thing it did was to go out at night
and fight crime the meaning for its own
existence came from Peter Parker who
spends most of his time fighting crime
however this had an unintended side
effect the symbiote two had bonded with
benevolent hosts infected the symbiotic
hive mind with traits such as nobility
and honor the good symbiotes eventually
rebelled against null and imprisoned him
at the center of their artificial planet
in the Andromeda galaxy eventually
creating the agents of the cosmos is a
force not of chaos but for good if you
needed proof that symbiotes weren't
designed with humans in mind that seems
like a pretty good indicator the fact
that noble humans were essentially able
to reprogram an evil alien symbiote hive
mind to be benevolent seems to indicate
that the symbiotes are not prepared for
the effects of what happens when they
bond with a completely new organism in
this case a human whether that meant
turning over a new leaf and rebelling
against their evil creator were simply
threatening to eat a dude in the middle
of the street and turning him into a
turd phantom is on an unfamiliar planet
fighting for his own survival and one of
the only weapons he has at his disposal
is imperfect mankind he's scared he's
threatened and he's doing his best to
survive the trailer for venom seems to
be trying to sell us on the idea that
venom is the one who's corrupting Eddie
Brock but who knows in the end Eddie
might just be the one who ends a
purifying venom but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and you know what I
thought to myself when I first saw venom
wow that guy is not taking great care of
his skin I mean look at this you guys
that is more than a little bit of
sunburn and overly enthusiastic
exfoliation I guess not everyone gets
themselves Dollar Shave Club every month
which is a shame since I think a lot of
this movie could have been resolved if
old Eddie Brock over there might have
cleaned up his act oobatz did a little
visit to the orthodontist may be treated
himself to some manly pampering Dollar
Shave Club our sponsor for today's
episode goes beyond merely its namesake
of Shaving and makes
like the calming body cleanser
apparently something that venom is not
been treating himself to recently
because if he had he wouldn't be looking
so rough around the edges shall we say
on the other hand maybe he's having a
really bad day with razor burn no razor
burn sucks bro that's why I'm telling
you that a little dollar shave club easy
shave butter will really take the edge
off so to speak so you'll be back to
breaking hearts instead of breaking
basically everything else in this movie
I relate to feeling like a monster
sometimes and needing to take better
care of myself pamper myself so to speak
so if you two have the monster building
inside of you and need a chance to relax
treat yourself to the new Dollar Shave
Club starter set Dollar Shave Club
basically put together a starter set of
their most popular products including
that body wash and that shave butter I
mentioned which are both awesome all in
a box for just five dollars along with
their executive razor the razor that I
just showed my father who is visiting
from out of town the other day and he's
like wow that is a really good razor and
I'm like yeah and it's inexpensive but
he's like that's great what a great
service
so Dollar Shave Club is dad Pat approved
and not only is their stuff awesome and
cheaper than you're gonna find in store
and also delivered right to your door
but they also make a lot of these
episodes possible they support this
channel but most importantly of all they
support view looking smelling and
feeling fantastic you can go check them
out at dollarshaveclub.com slash film
theory fi lm th e o ry right there at
the top of the description just begging
to be clicked on so go on make that
links existence worth it and once you're
on the other end remember it's only five
dollars that is like the same amount of
money that you spent on coffee this
morning and that certainly didn't make
your skin feel baby soft now if you'll
excuse me I need to go wrangle Eddie
Brock and talk to him about the
importance of moisturizing